[Music]
will is in tallahassee hi will how are
you
hey dave i'm doing fine how about
yourself better than i deserve sir
what's up in your world
so me and my wife are wanting to buy a
house but we've got about thirty
thousand dollars in debt right now
uh eighteen thousand is in student loans
and then twelve thousand is in a uh new
car zero percent interest on
and
we don't want to add to our debt
but my question is with the government
talking about maybe some student loan
forgiveness even though i don't agree
with it
would we be better off saving money
instead of paying on the student loans
right now or should we go ahead and
start paying on those loans yeah i'm
going to go ahead and start paying
and not because i agree or disagree
because i want you to control your life
and have agency over it which you have
and you know the zero percent car loan
which you mentioned i mean that's where
student loans are at and you don't want
to keep the car loan around do you
no i mean we don't want either one well
there we go you answered your own
question so i'm going to attack this
using the debt snowball method so list
all your debts smallest to largest if
the loans are split out just list them
all out there and attack the smallest
one first make minimum payments on the
rest and that's going to be your fastest
way to see progress on this debt and get
to that house eventually
so will here's the thing
if you just
all politics aside let's look at the
actual facts
of what has gone down and it helps you
analyze this okay
the government talking about forgiving
the student loans as a vague general
statement is not the way you should view
this
what you want to watch is this and so
this is fairly easy to predict here's
what's happening okay when president joe
biden was running for president one of
the things he talked about the whole
time was when he got to office to
forgive student loans
you remember that
yes sir
he's been in office two years
have they done anything
towards give forgiving student loans
actually don't i'm not talking about i'm
not talking about talk i'm talking about
actually
whether has there been any legislation
introduced any executive orders has he
done
anything
answer
no
no
okay now
he's in trouble
politically right now
because the economy is going down the
economy will get you thrown out of
office faster than anything else and all
those people with the same letter after
their name is yours so anybody's got a d
right now is in trouble
when it comes to the fall okay
this is just facts it's not political
analysis it's just common sense
so 100 chance
that he's going to start talking very
loudly about giving about forgiving
student loans between now and october
100 chance he's going to announce
something that sounds good but when you
read the details there's going to be
nothing it's going to be complete
political fluff and it'll be somewhere
in the month of september because he's
got to do something to try to prop up
the democrats as they go into the fall
elections because they're going to get
slaughtered based on this economy
right okay in other words
it's all bs
it's all political bs
and it and i'm i'm old okay
100 of the good things that have
happened to me
none of them came from washington dc
in my entire life
if you're waiting to have a good life on
something that comes from the white
house you're gonna have a life that
sucks
so you should just go ahead and fix your
own life george said it a different way
he said take agency over your own life
you take control plus as you said
all three of us are saying
well you me and george you signed the
paper you owe the money you ought to pay
the bill
there's a moral component to this too
okay and so roll up your sleeves young
man get your car paid off get your
student loan paid off and go get you
some money and buy a house and prosper
we want you to do that i want you to go
through financial peace university and
we're going to teach you how to handle
money and i'm going to pay for it i'm
going to give it to you for free hold on
i like you austin's going to pick up and
he's going to we're going to help you do
all of this good stuff